hello and welcome to this session on
logistic regression
I am Mohan Kumar from simply learn what
is logistic regression let's say we have
to build a predictive model on a machine
learning model to predict whether the
passengers of the Titanic ship have
survived or not the ship wrecked so how
do we do that so we use logistic
regression to build a model for this how
many use logistic regression so we have
the information about the passengers
their ID whether they have survived or
not their class and name and so on and
so forth and we use this information
where we already know whether the person
has survived or not that is the labeled
information and we help the system to
train based on this information with
based on this labeled data this is known
as label data and during the process of
building the model we probably will
remove some of the non-essential
parameters or attributes here we only
take those attributes which are really
required to make these predictions and
once we train the model we run new data
through it whereby the model will
predict whether the passenger has
survived or not so let's see what we'll
learn in this video we will talk about
what is supervised learning and we will
go into details about classification
which is one of the techniques for
supervised learning and then we will
further focus on logistic regression is
which is one of the algorithms for
performing classification specially
binary classification then we will
compare linear and logistic regression
and what are some of the logistic
regression of vacations and finally we
will end with a use case or a demo of
actual Python code for doing logistic
regression in Jupiter known all right so
let's start with what is supervised
learning supervised learning is one of
the two main types of machine learning
methods here we use what is known as
labelled data to help the system learn
this is very similar to how we be
so let's say you want to teach a child
to recognize an apple how do we do that
we never tell the child okay this is an
Apple has a certain diameter on the top
certain diameter bottom this as a
certain RGB color no we just show an
Apple to the child and tell the child is
a sample and then next time when we show
an Apple child immediately recognizes
yes this is an app supervised learning
works very similar of similar lines so
where does logistic regression fit into
the overall machine learning process
machine learning is divided into two
types mainly two types there is a third
one called reinforcement learning but we
will not talk about that right now so
one is supervised learning and the other
is unsupervised learn unsupervised
learning uses techniques like clustering
and Association and supervised learning
uses techniques like classification and
regression now supervised learning is
used when you have labeled data you have
historical data then you use supervised
learning when you don't have labeled
data then you used unsupervised learning
in supervised learning there are two
types of techniques that are used
classification and regression based on
what is the kind of problem we are
solved let's say we want to take the
data and classify it
it could be binary classification like a
0 or a 1 an example of classification we
have just seen whether the passenger has
survived or not survives like a 0 or 1
that is known as binary classification
regression on the other hand is you need
to predict or value what is known as a
continuous value
classification is for discrete values
regression is for continuous values
let's say you want to predict a share
price or you want to predict the
temperature that will be there what will
be the temperature to move that is where
you use regression where as
classification our discrete values is
will the customer buy the product or
will not buy the product will you get a
promotion or you will not get a
promotion I hope you're getting the idea
or it could be multi-class
classification as well let's say you
want to build an image classification
model so the image classic
model would take an image as an input
and classify into multiple classes
whether this image is of a cat or a dog
or an elephant or a tiger so there are
multiple classes are not necessarily
binary classification so that is known
as multi class classification so we are
going to focus on classification because
logistic regression is one of the
algorithms used for classification now
the name may be a little confusing in
fact whenever people come across
logistic regression it always causes
confusion because the name has a
regression in it but we are actually
using this for performing classification
okay so yes it is logistic regression
but it is used for classification in the
case you are wondering is there
something similar for regression yes for
regression we have linear regression
keep that in mind so linear regression
is used for regression logistic
regression is used for classification so
in this video we are going to focus on
supervised learning and within
supervised learning we are going to
focus on classification and then within
classification we are going to focus on
logistic regression algorithm so first
of all classification so what are the
way ms algorithms available for
performing classification the first one
is decision tree there are of course
multiple algorithms but here we will
talk about a few decision trees are
quite popular
I am very easy to understand and
therefore they use for classification
then we have K nearest neighbors this is
another algorithm for performing
classification and then there is
logistic regression this is what we are
going to focus on in this video and we
are going to go into little bit of
details about logistic regression all
right what is logistic regression as I
mentioned earlier rustic regression is
an algorithm for performing binary
classification so let's take an example
and see how this works let's say your
car has not been serviced for quite a
few years and now you want to find out
if it's going to break down in the near
future so this is like a classification
problem find out whether your car will
break
down or not so how are we going to
perform this classification so here's
how it looks if we plot the information
along the x and y axis X is the number
of years since then a service was
performed and Y is the probability of
your car breaking down and let's say
this information was this data rather
was collected from several car users
it's not just your car but several car
users so that is our labeled data so the
data has been collected and for for the
number of years and when the car broke
down and what was the probability and
that has been plotted along x and y axis
so this provides an idea from this graph
we can find out whether your car will
break down we'll see how so first of all
the probability can go from 0 to 1 as
you're aware probability can be between
0 and 1 and as we can imagine it is
intuitive as well as the number of ears
are on the lower side maybe one year two
years or three years - after the service
the chances of your car breaking down
are very limited friends so for example
chances of your car breaking down the
probability of your car breaking down
within two years of your last service
are point one properly similarly three
years is maybe 0.3 and so on but as the
number of years increases let's say if
it was six or seven years there is
almost a certainty that your car is
going to break down that is what this
graph shows so this is an example of a
application of the classification
algorithm and we will see in little
details how exactly logistic regression
is applied here
one more thing needs to be added here is
that the dependent variables outcome is
discreet so if we are talking about
whether the car is going to break down
or not so that is a discrete value the Y
that we are talking about the dependent
variable that we are talking about what
we are looking at is whether the car is
going to break down or not yes or no
that is what we are talking about
so here the outcome is
screed and not a continuous file so this
is how the logistic regression curve
looks let me explain a little bit what
exactly how exactly we are going to
determine the class the outcome rather
so for a logistic regression curve a
threshold has to be set saying that
because this is a probability
calculation remember this is a
probability calculation and the
probability itself will not be 0 or 1
but based on the probability we need to
decide what the outcome should be so
there has to be a threshold like for
example 0.5 can be the threshold let's
say in this case so any value of the
probability below 0.5 is considered to
be 0 and any value above 0.5 is
considered to be 1 so an output of let's
say 0.8 will mean that the car will
break down so that is considered as an
output of 1 and let's say an output of
0.29 is considered as 0 which means that
the car will not break down so that's
the way for cystic regression works now
let's do a quick comparison between
logistic regression and linear
regression because they both have the
term regression in them so that can
cause confusion so let's try to remove
that confusion so what is linear
regression linear regression is a
process this once again an algorithm for
supervised learning however here you are
going to find a continuous well you are
going to determine a continuous well it
could be the price of a real estate
property it could be your hike much hike
you're going to get or it could be a
stock price these are all continuous
values these are not discrete compared
to our yes or no kind of a response that
we are looking for in logistic
regression so this is one example of
linear regression let's say the HR team
of a company tries to find out what
should be the salary hike of an employee
so they collect all the details of their
existing employees their ratings and
their salary hikes what has been given
and that is the labeled information that
is available and the system learns from
this it is trained and it learns from
this label information
so that when a new employees information
is fed based on the rating it will
determine what should be the high so
this is a linear regression problem in
linear regression example no salary is a
continuous value you can get five
thousand five thousand five hundred five
thousand six hundred it is not discrete
like a cat or a dog or an apple or a
banana these are discrete or a yes or a
No these are discrete values right so
this way you are trying to find
continuous values is where we use linear
regression so let's say just to extend
on this scenario we now want to find out
whether this employee is going to get a
promotion or not so we want to find out
if that is a discrete problem right yes
or no kind of problem in this case we
actually cannot use linear regression
even though we may have labeled data so
this is the label data so based on the
employee rating these are the ratings
and then some people got the promotion
and this is the ratings for which people
did not get promotion that is a no and
this is the rating for which people got
promotion we just plotted the data about
whether a person has got an employee has
got promotion or not yes no right so
there is nothing in between and what is
the employees rating and ratings can be
continuous that is not an issue but the
output is discrete in this case whether
an employee got promotion yes no so if
we try to plot that and we try to find a
straight line this is how it would look
and as you can see doesn't look very
right because looks like there will be
lot of errors this truth mean square
error if you remember for linear
regression would be very very high and
also the the values cannot go beyond
zero or beyond one so the graph should
probably look somewhat like this tipped
at zero and one but still the straight
line doesn't look right therefore
instead of using a linear equation we
need to come up with something different
and therefore the logistic regression
model
somewhat like this so we calculate the
probability and if we plot that
probability not in the form of a
straight line but you need to use some
other equation we will see very soon
what that equation is then it is a
gradual process alright so you see here
people with some of these ratings are
not getting any promotions and then
slowly at certain rating they get
promotion so that is a gradual process
and this is how the math behind logistic
regression looks so we are trying to
find odds for a particular event
happening and this is the formula for
finding the odd so the probability of an
event happening divided by the
probability of the event not happening
so P if it is the probability of the
event happening probability of the
person getting a promotion and divided
by the probability of the person not
getting a promotion that is 1 minus P
this is how you measure the odds now the
values of the odds range from 0 to
infinity so when this probability is 0
then the odds will the value of the odds
is equal to 0 and when the probability
becomes 1 then the value of the odds is
1 by 0 that will be infinity but the
probability itself remains between 0 and
1 now this is how an equation of a
straight line law so y is equal to beta
0 plus beta 1 X where beta 0 is the
y-intercept and beta 1 is the slope of
the line if we take the odds equation
and take a log of both sides then this
would look somewhat like this and the
term logistic it's actually derived from
the fact that we are doing this we take
a log of px by 1 minus px this is an
extension of the calculation of odds
that we have seen right and that is
equal to beta 0 plus beta 1 X which is
the equation of the straight line and
now from here if you want to find out
the value of P X you will see we can
take the exponential on both sides and
then if we solve that equation we will
get the equation
vx like this P X is equal to 1 by 1 plus
e to the power of minus beta 0 plus beta
1 X and recall this is nothing but the
equation of the line which is equal to Y
Y is equal to beta 0 plus beta 1 X so
that this is the equation also known as
the sigmoid function and this is the
equation of the logistic regression and
alright and if this is plotted this is
how the sigmoid curve is obtained so
let's compare linear and logistic
regression how they are different from
each other let's go back so linear
regression is solved or used to solve
regression problems and logistic
regression is used to solve
classification firms so both are called
regression but linear regression is used
for solving regression problems where we
predict continuous levels whereas
logistic regression is used for solving
classification problems we have had to
predict discrete values the response
variables in case of linear regression
are continuous in nature whereas here
they are categorical or discrete in
nature and linear regression helps to
estimate the dependent variable when
there is a change in the independent
variable whereas here in case of
logistic regression it helps to
calculate the probability or the
possibility of a particular event happen
and linear regression as the name
suggests is a straight line that's why
it's called linear regression
whereas logistic regression is a sigmoid
function and the curve is the shape of
the curve is yes it's an s-shaped curve
this is another example of application
of logistic regression in weather
prediction that it's going to rain or
not rain
now keep in mind both are used in
weather prediction if we want to find
the discrete values like whether it's
going to rain or not rain that is a
classification problem we use logistic
regression but if we want to determine
what is going to be the temperature
tomorrow then we use linear regression
so just keep in mind that in weather
prediction we actually use both but
these are some examples of logistic
regression so we want to find out
whether it's going to be rain or not
there is going to be sunny or not
is going to snow or not these are all
logistic regression examples a few more
examples classification of objects this
is again another example of logistic
regression now here of course one
distinction is that these are
multi-class classification so logistic
regression is not used in its original
form but it is used in a slightly
different form so we say whether it is a
dog or not a dog I hope you understand
so instead of saying is it a dog or a
cat or a elephant we convert this into
saying so because we need to keep it to
binary classification so we say is it a
dog or not at all is it a cat or not
okay so that's the way logistic
regression can be used for classifying
objects otherwise there are other
techniques which can be used for
performing multi-class classification
you have done strict regression is used
to find the survival rate of a patient
so they take multiple parameters like
trauma score and age and so on and so
forth and they try to predict the rate
of survival all right now finally let's
take an example and see how we can apply
logistic regression to predict the
number that is shown in the image so
this is actually a live demo I will take
you into Jupiter notebook and show the
call but before that let me take you to
a couple of slides to explain what we
are trying to do so let's say you have
an 8 by 8 image and the image has a
number 1 2 3 4 and you need to train
your model to predict what this number
is so how do we do this so the first
thing is obviously in any machine
learning process you train your model so
in this case we are using logistic
regression so and then we provide the
training set to train the model and then
we test how accurate our model is with
the test data which means that like any
machine learning process we split or
initial data into two parts training set
and lesson with the training set we
trained over model and then with the S
set we we test the model till we get
good accuracy and then we use it for for
influence right so that is typical
methodology of training testing and
deploying machine learning models so
let's take a look at the code and see
what we are doing so I'd not go line by
line but just take you through some of
the blocks so first thing we do is
import all the libraries and then we
basically take a look at the images and
see what is the total number of images
we can display using matplotlib some of
the images or a sample of these images
and then we split the data into training
and test as I mentioned earlier and we
can do some exploratory analysis and
then we build our model we train our
model with the training set and then we
test it with our test set and find out
how accurate our model is using the
confusion matrix the heat map and use
heat map for visualizing this and I will
show you in the code what exactly is the
confusion matrix and how it can be used
for finding the accuracy in our example
we can we get an accuracy of about 0.9 4
which is pretty good or 94% which is
pretty good all right so what is the
confusion matrix this is an example of a
confusion matrix and this is used for
identifying the accuracy of
classification model are like a large
stick regression model so the most
important part in conclusion matrix is
that first of all this as you can see
this is a matrix and the size of the
matrix depends on how many outputs we
are expecting so the most important part
here is that the model will be most
accurate when we have the maximum
numbers in its diagonal
like in this case that's why it has
almost 93 94 percent because the
diagonals should have the maximum
numbers and the others other than
diagonals the cells other than the
diagnose should have very few numbers so
here that's what is happening so there
is a 2 here there are there's a 1 here
but most of them are along the diagonals
this what does this mean this means that
the number that
has been fed is zero and the number that
has been detected is also zero so the
predicted value and actual value are the
same so along the diagonals that is true
which means that let's let's take this
diagonals right if the maximum number is
here that means that like here in this
case it is 34 which means that 34 of the
images that have been fed or rather
actually there are two
misclassifications in there so 36 images
have been fed which have number four and
out of which 34 have been predicted
correctly as number four and one has
been predicted as number eight and
another one has been predicted as number
nine so these are two misclassifications
okay so that is the meaning of saying
that the maximum number should be in the
diagram so if you have all of them so
for an ideal model which has let's say
100% accuracy
everything will be only in the diagram
there will be no numbers other than zero
in all other cells so that is like 100%
accurate model okay so that's just of
how to use this matrix how to use this
confusion matrix I know the name is a
little funny sounding confusion matrix
but actually it is not very confusing
it's very straight forward so you are
just plotting what has been predicted
and what is the labeled information or
what is the actual data that's also
known as the ground truth sometimes
these are some fancy terms that are you
so predicted label and actually that's
all it is
okay yeah so they are showing a little
bit more information here so 38 have
been predicted and here you will see
that all of them have been predicted
correctly there have been 38 zeroes and
the predicted value and actual value is
exactly the same whereas in this case
right it has there are I think 37 plus
542 have been fed damages 42 images are
digit 3 and the accuracy is only 37 of
them have been accurately predicted
three of them have been predicted as
number seven and two of them
eight and so on and so forth all right
so with that let's go into Jupiter
notebook and see how the code looks so
this is the code in in Jupiter notebook
for logistic regression in this
particular demo what we are going to do
is train our model to recognize digits
which are the images which have digits
from let's say 0 to 5 or 0 to 9 and and
then we will see how well it is trained
and whether it is able to predict these
numbers correctly or not so let's get
started so the first part is as usual we
are importing some libraries that are
required and then the last line and this
block is to load the digits so let's go
ahead and run this code then here we
will visualize the shape of these digits
so we can see here if we take a look
this is how the shape is 1797 by 64
these are like 8 by 8 images so that's
that's what is reflected in this shape
now from here onwards we are basically
once again importing some of the
libraries that are required like numpy
and my plot and we will take a look at
some of the sample images that we have
unloaded so this one for example creates
a figure and then we go ahead and take a
few sample images to see how they look
so lets me run this corner so that it
becomes easy to understand so these are
about 5 images sample images that we are
looking at 0 1 2 3 4 so this is how the
image is this now the data is ok and
based on this we will actually train our
logistic regression model and then we
will test it and see how well it is able
to recognize so the way it works is the
pixel information so as you can see here
this is an 8 by 8 pixel kind of a image
and the each pixel whether it is
activated or not activated that is the
information available for each pixel now
based on the pattern
of this activation and non activation of
the various pixels this will be
identified as a zero for example right
similarly as you can see
so overall each of these numbers
actually has a different pattern of the
pixel activation and that's pretty much
that our model needs to learn for which
a number what is the pattern of the
activation of the pixels right so that
is what we are going to train our model
ok so the first thing we need to do is
to split our data into training and test
data set right so whenever we perform
any training we split the data into
training and tests so that the training
data set is used to train the system so
we pass this probably multiple times and
then we test it with the test data set
and the split is usually in the form of
there and there are various ways in
which you can split this data it is up
to the individual references in our case
here we are splitting in the form of 23
and 77 so when we say test size as
twenty point two three
that means 23 percent of that entire
data is used for testing and the
remaining 77 percent is used for
training so there is a readily available
function which is called train test
split so we don't have to write any
special code for the splitting it will
automatically split the data based on
the proportion that we give here which
is test size so we just give the test
size automatically training size will be
determined and we pass the data that we
want to split and the results will be
stored in X underscore train and Y
underscore train for the training data
set and what is X underscore train
deserve these are the features right
which is like the independent variable
and Y underscore train is the label
right so in this case what happens is we
have the input value which is or the
features value which is in X underscore
train and since this is the labeled data
for each of them each of the
observations we
already have the label information
saying whether this digit is a 0 or a 1
or a 2 so that dips and this is what
will be used for comparison to find out
whether the the system is able to
recognize it correctly or there is an
error for each observation it will
compare with this right so this is the
labor so the same way X underscore train
Y underscore train is for the training
data set X underscore test y underscore
test is further test data set okay so
let me go ahead and execute this code as
well and then we can go and check
quickly what is the how many entries are
there and in each of this so X
underscore train the shape is 1383 by 64
and y underscore train has 1383 because
there is nothing like the second part is
not required here and then X underscore
test shape we see is 4 1 4 so actually
there are 414 observations in test and
1383 observations in train so that's
basically what these four lines of code
are are saying ok then we import the
logistic regression library and which is
a part of scikit-learn so we don't have
to implement the logistic regression
process itself we just call these
function and let me go ahead and execute
that so that we have the logistic
regression library imported now we
create an instance of logistic
regression right so logistic re gr is is
an instance of logistic regression and
then we use that for training our model
so let me in first execute this code so
these two lines so the first line
basically creates an instance of
logistic regression model and then the
second line where is where we are
passing our data the training data set
and this is our the predictors and this
is our target we are passing this data
set to train our model all right so once
we do this in this case the data is not
large but by and large the training is
what takes usually a lot of time so we
spend in
machine learning activities in machine
learning projects we spend a lot of time
for the training part of it okay so here
the data set is relatively small so it
was pretty quick so alright so now our
model has been trained using the
training data set and we want to see how
accurate this is so what we will do is
we will test it out in probably faces so
let me first try out how well this is
working for one image okay I will just
try it out with one image my the first
entry in my tester our data set and see
whether it is correctly predicting or
not so and in order to test it so for
training purpose we use the fit method
there is a method called fit which is
for training the model and once the
training is done if you want to test for
a particular value new input you use the
predict method okay so let's run the
predict method and we pass this
particular image and we see that the
shape is or the prediction is four so
let's try a few more
let me see for the next ten seems to be
fine
and so let me just go ahead and test the
entire dataset
okay that's basically so now we want to
find out how accurately this has
performed so we use the score method to
find what is the percentages of accuracy
and we see here that it has performed up
to 94% to accurate okay so that's on
this part now what we can also do is we
can also see this accuracy using what is
known as a confusion matrix so let us go
ahead and try that as well so that we
can also visualize how well this model
has done so let me execute this piece of
code which will basically import some of
the libraries that are required and we
we basically create a confusion matrix
and instance of confusion matrix by
running confusion matrix and passing
these values so we have so this
confusion underscore matrix method takes
two parameters one is the y underscore
test and the other is the prediction so
what is the why underscore test these
are the labeled values which we already
know for the test data set and
predictions are what the system is
predicted for the test data set okay so
this is known to us and this is what the
system has the model has generated so we
kind of create the confusion matrix and
we will print it and this is how the
confusion matrix looks as the name
suggests it is a matrix and the key
point out here is that the accuracy of
the model is determined by how many
numbers are there in the diagonal the
more the numbers in the diagonal the
better the accuracy is okay and first of
all the total sum of all the numbers in
this whole matrix is equal to the number
of observations in the test data set
that is the first thing right so if you
add up all these numbers that will be
equal to the number of observations in
that test data set and then out of that
the maximum number of them should be in
the diagonals that means the accuracy is
pretty good if the the numbers in the
diagonals are less and in all other
places there are a lot of numbers which
means the accuracy is very low the
diagonal indicates a correct prediction
so this means that the actual value is
same as the predicted value here again
actual value same as a predictive value
and so on right so the moment you see a
number here that means the actual value
is something and the predicted value is
something else right similarly here the
actual value is something and the
predicted value is something else so
that is basically how we read the
confusion matrix now how do we find the
accuracy you can actually add up the
total values in the diagonals so it's
like 38 plus 44 plus 43 and so on and
divide that by the total number of test
observations that will give you the
percentage accuracy using a confusion
matrix now let us visualize this
confusion matrix a in a slightly more
sophisticated way using a heat map so we
will create a heat map with some
add some colors as well it's it's like
more visually visually more appealing so
that's the whole idea so if we let me
run this piece of court and this is how
the heat map looks and as you can see
here the diagonals again are all the
values are here most of the values so
which means reasonably this seems to be
reasonably accurate and yeah basically
the accuracy score is 94% this is
calculated as I mentioned by adding all
these numbers divided by the total test
values or the total number of
observations in test data set okay so
this is the confusion matrix for
logistic regression
alright so now that we have seen the
confusion matrix let's take a quick
sample and see how well the system has
classified and we will take a few
examples of the data so if we see here
we be picked up randomly a few of them
so this is number 4 which is the actual
value and also the predicted value both
are 4 this is an image of a zero so the
predicted value is also 0 actual values
of course zero then this is the image of
9 so this has also been predicted
correctly 9 and actual value is 9 and
this is the image of 1 and again this
has been predicted correctly as like the
actual value okay
so this was a quick demo of logistic
regression how to use logistic
regression to identify images okay so
let's summarize what we have learnt in
this video we discussed about what is
logistic regression and how it fits into
the overall machine learning we
discussed about the different types of
machine learning and how logistic
regression is one of the algorithms for
classification and then we compared
logistic regression with linear
regression because the names may be
sounding similar but these are
completely different algorithms linear
regression is used for predicting
continuous values whereas logistic
regression is used for finding discrete
waves and then we talked about the math
behind
District regression and we derived that
function as well the sigmoid function we
did a quick Tabler comparison between
linear and logistic regression we saw
some examples of day-to-day life how a
logistic regression is used for some of
the class for solving some of the
classification problems and then in the
end we looked at the code to see how we
can implement logistic regression to
train the model to identify images with
that we come to the end of the session
thank you very much for watching this
video for more information visit us at
www.simpleandsensational.com
[Music]